what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so in Marvel Comics when it comes
to reality war furs there's a lot of
them out there
but if I'm being honest with you guys
Clyde winch him like the marquee of
death is just read like he hate hops
almost all of them well you could count
on one hand the number of people who
could successfully defeat or the number
of beings who could successfully defeat
the marquee of death so the order of the
marquee of death was originally that he
was a guy named Clyde Winship and he was
just like he was a kid who was born in
in a universe where he was the only one
that had any mutant powers and they were
reality-warping powers but the idea was
a Clyde when she was he was this guy
this kid who was born and his dad had
died when he was younger and so he
resurrected his dad from the dead and
his mom freaked out hit him over the
head gave him brain damage and he spent
the rest of his days in an asylum now
along the line while he was in this
asylum the nurses took his comics away
and so what he did is he took the
superheroes from the main Marvel
Universe and brought them into his
universe he literally plucked them out
of the main Marvel Universe and brought
them into his universe and so people
were starting to freak out there like
what in the hell's going on here like
Captain America's a comic book character
how does he exist here and so that
turned into everybody tracing the the
origin of this back to Clyde winch I'm
Reed Richards figured out what was going
on and then he basically said look man
if what you want is to live in a world
of superheroes then we'll bring you to
our universe and so they did they they
brought him to the main mobile universe
and they stuck him in this place called
area 87 and a helmet was put on his head
so he would just have like these perfect
dreams for all eternity that was the
original story for Clyde winter he was
just supposed to be written out of
existence and that was the end of it all
right fast-forward to like Mark Miller
or mark Wade's run on the Fantastic Four
I can't which one and there's just like
this guy in the future right let's like
this dude in the future who literally
looks like a why he looks like Skeletor
Lisa's like a walking talking skull and
so on and so forth the way he went when
Mark E of death is first introduced he's
in this alternate reality where he and
his apprentice have killed everybody on
earth except for Reed Richards and Susan
storm I think just to torture them and
then like in these moments they sit the
Sun to supernova destroy the world and
then like with a wave of his hand wiped
out the universe and he and his
apprentice left I mean it was it was it
was insane it was just like a wave of
his hand and the universe just gets
obliterated and it's just like Christ
like that's some living tribunals types
that right so the marquee of death shows
up in the main Marvel Universe right
it's like okay let's like where's my red
where's my next time we're gonna go to
the main Marvel Universe because it's
like the great cleansing or something
along those lines when the marquee of
death and his apprentice wipe out all
the population of an
of iner and so day they go to like the
main Marvel Universe and they confront
dr. doom and dr. doom like recognizes
the marquee of death and that's when you
learn a lot of the skills that dr. doom
learned over the course of his life came
from the marquee of death and it kind of
worked because in dr. Doom's original
origin he learned like his initial
understanding of sorcery from like
mystics and he didn't really know where
he gained like the rest of his amiss
magical knowledge you just knew that he
did and then just kind of went with it I
mean he assumed it was his own
independent study but like the marquee
of death is like his teacher basically
and the marquee of death is like you
bring shame because you've been
constantly defeated by the Fantastic
Four and so like dr. doom freaks out
right like dr. doom goes to attack the
marquee of death and then like all the
Earth's superheroes show up and attack
the marquee of death and and ennis
insane like like it's like this this
massive coming together of the entire
superhero community and like like every
superhero every super it like the whole
nine yards every person with powers
shows up and attach the marquee of death
and Doctor Doom wins right like like
they defeat the marquee of death and
it's just like damned so like like
Doctor Doom is champion is like this
hero of the world right like Reed
Richards dies in the process like a lot
of people die dr. doom marries Susan
storm and they have a kid together and
then that's when you realize the whole
thing is an illusion from the time all
the superheroes came together and all
the supervillains came together to
defeat the marquee of death until the
point when dr. doom is talking to Susan
storm it was on illusion all those years
he lived was all in illusion not only
that only five seconds had passed and
the marquee of death is like this is how
hopelessly outmatched you are you don't
stand a chance you never stood a chance
and then like like from that point like
literally opens a time rift throws dr.
doom into the mouth of a shark into the
mouth of a Megalodon shark and then just
goes back and is just like let's kill
everyone and so it's just like damn like
this it's dudas it's it's it's insane
and so like Diddy shows up to the Baxter
building and and like goes to the
Fantastic Four and just starts
systematically torturing the Fantastic
Four right like he shows he shows Johnny
Storm like all the alternate reality
versions of Susan storm that he killed
he tries to get Reed Richards to kill
his son Franklin I mean like this is all
these crazy things that go on and so Ben
Grimm the thing ends up going to area 87
and grabbing a Clyde winch um and then
bringing him over and what you find out
is when Reed Richards originally took
Clyde winch him and took him to area 87
and then dropped him off that at some
point after the present day which is to
say when this huge fights going on at
some point in the future all the
villains attack area 87 and they free
clyde winch him and then claude wynjym
kills them all and then clyde when jim
goes into the
future innovation like he goes on to
eventually become the marquee of death
the marquee is Clyde he's just a future
version of him and so it's basically
present-day Clyde versus future Clyde
and future Clyde went and the result is
that you end up finding out the
apprentice is actually dr. doom like
it's been dr. doom the whole time
somewhere along the line that when dr.
doom was thrown into the past and eaten
by like a Megalodon shark that he
survived and spent the next like
millions and millions and millions and
millions and millions of years modifying
his physical form enhancing his powers
so that later on in the future when when
he encountered the marquee of death and
became as apprentice the marquee of
death wouldn't know it was dr. doom and
so from from that point like when the
marquee of death realizes that his
Doctor Doom he's been talking to this
whole time like he begs for his life and
doom is like shut up and then just kills
him just like just just wipes it but the
only reason dr. doom was able to kill
him was because Clyde watch him junior
weakened like the marquee of death
enough that he could kill him this is
what the marquee of death could never
exist in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because like like imagine Avengers 4
ends and imagine that like the curtain
gets pulled back and you end up
realizing that all of this has happened
in the span of like one minute when I
say everything I mean like the entire
life and times of Tony Stark the whole
life of Captain America Natasha Romanoff
all those characters that in reality
Natasha Romanoff is like a shopkeeper in
Russia who's like overweight and forty
and like dreams of being like a
world-class assassin Captain America is
this this fifteen-year-old kid who gets
bullied all the time and Tony Stark is a
failed inventor and Bruce Banner is a is
a guy who had dreams of becoming a
scientist and just like failed out of
every chemistry class he took and like
they're all just like regular people and
just out of sheer curiosity just to kind
of have fun the marquee of death gave
them like this perfect rillette like
this is this unit where they became
everything they wanted to and they were
fighting against insurmountable odds
Hana's with the Infinity Gauntlet an all
I kind of saw in a1 and then it's just
like no this was all an illusion I was
just having fun all these movies in the
MCU all took place over the span of like
one minute if that's possible with the
marquee of death and that's why you
wouldn't be able to work in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is because like with
all the carries we've talked about to
this point they've had reasonable
weaknesses the marquee of death isn't
like that like the marquee of death is
invulnerable and indestructible and and
like on a scale of absolute power in
terms of like where he resides like if
we had to adjust the Marvel cosmic
hierarchy with things as they stand now
in reality I would put like the one
above all the beyonders and in the
Living Tribunal and then
maybe off to the side of the Living
Tribunal the marquee of death here's
what here's a reason why okay so so take
take like Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers you have to beyonders
who are going through and they're just
like annihilating the cosmic entities
like hank pam is sent out into the into
the multiverse to try to find the source
of the incursions and he says i found
them the white lords of wild space the
ivory kings it's the beyonders man and
and he's like he's like all hope is lost
and it's like well what do you mean we
can't like there has to be a way to beat
them it's like no we can't beat them
like I was floating in the universe and
I just kind of wondered into some
universe somewhere and I saw the
beyonders just annihilating all the
cosmic entities like that and that
entire universe just shattered into a
million pieces and was totally wiped
away by the beyonders The Living
Tribunal shows up and the beyonders
destroy the load they destroy the the
representation of the multiverse I
watched them do that Captain America you
can punch really hard what are we gonna
do against power like that but even then
like you look at the beyond you look at
them and you say okay it took three of
them to destroy the living tribe you
know and then like the way it's
explained by hank pym it was difficult
for them to delay not really difficult
but like it took time for them to
destroy the Celestials and like the the
cosmic entities and so on and so forth
and those are beings that reside in a
singular universe the marquee of death
waved his hand and wiped them all out
cosmic entities and all wave this hand
that means that like in that universe
Galactus the Silver Surfer all the
superheroes who existed on any one
particular planet like the molecule man
who would exist in that universe
Franklin Richards who would exist in
that universe protege who might exist in
that universe like all those characters
just wiped away by the marquee of death
and that's assuming they even existed in
that universe in the first place you
know there's to say like protege and
molecule Manus 1 but they were evil to
their to their cells in the main Marvel
Universe but like making that assumption
then like you're talking about an insane
level of power and there's no
conceivable way that character could be
defeated in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because it took his present-day
self in order to weaken his future self
enough for Doctor Doom to be able to
defeat him I mean it was it was
absolutely bonkers like so far in the
most cinematic universe the most
powerful thing we've seen it stands with
the Infinity stones that doesn't matter
against the marquee of death Thanos
would show up and I've brought the
Infinity stone you can have all of your
superheroes who would all band together
at the annals will show up with you know
with with the Infinity stones all the
x-men right like every single mutant on
the face of the planet Earth and like
everyone who could be an Avenger every
super-powered being that you've ever
heard of in model Comics they could all
band together and face off against the
marquee of death and it wouldn't matter
he would still destroy them all there's
there's no conceivable hope for them to
win like there's there's no possible way
they could defeat that the marquee of
death is a character you don't you know
what the marquee of death is a character
you bring in went in like five hundred
years Disney and them are finished
making Marvel movies and they say how
are we gonna destroy our multiverse or
destroy everything we'll just have the
marquee of death wipe it all out like
that's when you bring his character in
to the MCU
it's a crazy Display of power I mean
there's no real conceivable weaknesses
to his character aside from like his
counterpart in the past and that's
really it's kind of crazy it's kind of
bonkers but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb floor if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]